this is crazy cuz this is what I wanted
to ask you about okay which is you make
these playlists and you make them for
your friends but you make them for some
of the most famous people in the world
you like Barack
Obama asked you to make a playlist for
him do you ever throw something in there
just like the theme from Gilligan Island
just something that's going to freak him
out oh I I do that all the like the the
amount of he
doesn't he doesn't uh question much
there's a few people are like did you
really mean to to to put this version of
that song on there like I will lightly
troll I'm not trying to troll more than
I'm just trying to expand the pallet yep
because I think often times when it
comes to streaming there are billions of
songs out there but we're only going to
go to the 32 songs that we know yes and
I'm willing
to do the the musical metaphorical uh
equivalent of the Shaw Shank crawl
uh and and go through I go through about
500 songs a week uh of which
maybe seven are cool and add that to the
database and these are songs that I
believe in like not like desert island
disc but like I cosign the song and
every part of the song has to be like
something that yeah this is a great song
and yeah it it started with the Obamas
um and then I added the Carters like
when they were I wanted to add people
that just had kids so in my mind when
when Blue Ivy was born I was like okay
right I'm gonna I want you to play this
like in her crib or in her Nursery
whatever and then cuz if you can reach a
kid before six you can really determine
their creativity what I love about this
is that when you do this you are in a
very intimate way in the ear of uh of a
Barack Obama do you know what I mean
mean and you're you're able to you're
you're like creating new neural Pathways
by throwing in a uh tricker for kids
commercial really quickly you're
with full
circle you're screwing with the mind of
uh of a of a of a president of the
United States which is fascinating to me
I believe that music is sort of
nourishing like food and the right song
could inspire you to so I do two types
of playlists I do an afternoon playlist
that should be played between 7:00 a.m.
and 6:00 uh p.m. and then I do an
evening playlist between 6 and that
doesn't mean like Hey Baby Quiet Storm
music it's not that but I do an evening
set so it started with them and then it
was 10 and then it was the 50 so I think
right about
[Music]
now oh my God that's a lot of scrolling
I text 700 times a month to and there's
the uh there's the the list of
people you might know some of the names
ice on there oh my God there is no
Robbie vanwinkle okay I'm adding Vanilla
Ice I can't believe I'm holding your
list and this is the most impressive
list of names I don't want to I want to
respect people's privacy no they I mean
they're you know it's it's let's hear it
yeah just say it no I well okay I I
there's just I mean is in here yeah
which is uh and you got Bill hater yeah
bill bill is a music head I I'll say
that of of my top 30 like responding
people like people that actually like
give feedback like wow this song really
changed my life in 1932 and I'll be like
I'm on the touret or something like that
but no ke Keenan Thompson's in here
rashita Jones Nora Jones this is amazing
Martha Stewart Jesus yeah Martha is
she's come a long way yeah no she's
amazing come she has That's My love
language so my question is will you be
342 you bet I will I would be honored I
would be honored to be on this list this
is a such a cool list of people there
you go this is absolutely wow Ron to
santis oh no
yeah I'm surprised to see that name but
I'm glad you're working on the
guy forite for like 2.3 seconds I was
like wait how did he get
on I would love it I would love it if
Ronda sandis was like you know when I'm
shipping unsuspecting immigrants to
Nantucket I like to calm down
occasionally with Quest
loves Quest Love's playlist this is so
cool please put me on this right this
means that we're going to have to
actually be friends now yeah so all
right
so oh it's official does he know what to
do oh or I know what to do does he own
iPhone check with me to make sure his
phone number is right yeah I change
he'll know I change my phone number a
lot constantly no he doesn't I don't
trust people that change their numbers
that I don't I I don't change it a lot
that's my excuse for do you have that
one professional in which you have to
have like blah blah blah new blah blah
blah three you know was true there was
an ERA in my life in the '90s when I had
like regular you know before these
phones like a flip phone where my my
number kept getting out there and
fraternities would call me this but it
was always they were always upbeat there
I was like dude is this C O'Brian and
like an idot give your number away I
don't know and I would say I yeah it
would be me uh no no they would give my
number away and then they would call me
and I'd hear cheering in the background
and I had some pretty good
conversations I'll bet
you is someone writing your name like a
bathroom stall or something like that or
they are now for a good time for a lame
time